[Music]
Hi, how are you? I'm Héctor Mejía with the
briefing for today, Wednesday
, March 10. This morning, the police are
looking for a suspect who
hit and killed a driver and
then fled. It happened around
8 o'clock.  at night on highway 215
in geyter the victim was working on
the side when the driver of an
avant hit him the detectives are now
looking for a white ford bullet with
damage to the front and in other
news the sweet experience magnet in the
downtown is looking to hire
full time staff jobs
include slot machine operators
plus security guards officers and
vendors there will be a job fair on
March 25 from 2pm to 4pm
however you can now apply
online  the software knights will play with the
public from March 20
health officials indicated that they
will be able to allow 15 percent
capacity on the site more than 1000
tickets  they will go on
sale starting at 10 in the morning for the
matches during this month inside the
ring are ring and now we go to
the weather forecast we will have some
drizzle and snow in the mountains today
Wednesday we will
reach maximum temperatures
in the 50s and then  they will increase as we get
closer to the weekend have a
nice day I am héctor mejía and this
was your kirchner newscast in
spanish